Pfizer ultimately is thinking about
mutating covet
well there's not always
like not you know how the virus keeps
mutating yeah well one of the things
we're exploring is like why don't we
just mutate ourselves so we could well
I'm typically develop new vaccines right
so we have to do that if we're going to
do that though there's a risk of like as
you could imagine no one wants to be
having what was he recording him with
right here was he doing it with like a
spy camera I don't know uh farmer
company mutating this seem to be like
very controlled to make sure that this
virus that you mutate it doesn't create
something like you know it's those
everywhere something crazy correct is
the wave of the virus targets to be
honest like it's it makes no sense that
desires walked out of nowhere like yeah
I know me Jordan Tristan Walker a
director of research and development
strategic operations and mRNA scientific
planning advisor it sounds like gain a
function to me
it's like this
it's definitely not gain a function it
sounds like it is I mean it's okay
what is the exact definition of games
Google it on the computer on the
keyboard gain a function mutation
definition a type of mutation in which
the altar Gene product possesses a new
molecular function or a new pattern of
gene expression okay all right I don't
understand that anymore
[Laughter]
but you do like things like selected
Direction mutations to try and see if
you can make more protein yeah so there
the areas research I'm going about that
I don't know how that's gonna work we're
not being more outbreaks to Think Jesus
Christ the gentleman seems to have
absolutely no moral compass at all so
all government officials it's pretty
good for the industry to be honest yeah
yeah it's bad for everyone else in
America why is it bad for everybody else
was it the regulator
know that once they stop being a regular
they want to work for the company
if this is the quality of individuals
within Pfizer that are making these huge
decisions that risk Global Public Health
it's profoundly corrupt so basically
he's saying we're we're talking about
creating new strains to sell more
vaccines to help with whether or not it
becomes so dangerous that we can't
control it and people die just so that
we can create another vaccine and sell
it and make billions of dollars you know
the most interesting part about this
thing is is that the media hasn't
covered it at all basically no so the
media is ignoring it this is direct
proof that people only care about what
shook down their throat because if the
media was this is what was shoved down
people's throat in the news and social
media this is what they would talk about
and this is what they care about but
when all they talk about is this virus
that you haven't seen anyone you know
you don't see a virus around you you
know you don't see a pandemic like let's
be real like like what entertainment a
good point about that he's like did
anybody actually see a pandemic do you
see ambulances flying up the street do
you see hospitals filled did you see
like a real pandemic with your eyes if
you weren't told people who worked in
hospitals went through a lot of [__] if
you weren't told no people who worked in
in the hospitals went through a lot of
[__]
okay but if you weren't told
because you're just acting like nobody
went through anything it's not what I'm
saying I'm saying if you weren't told
that kovid was this big horrible thing
you wouldn't have even noticed it
telling you if you if nobody was told
that there was Covenant we just kept
living the world would still be going
fine it would be going better actually
if we're going to be honest here no I'm
not going to pretend that covert wasn't
real I'm not saying it wasn't real and
that it wasn't dangerous for something
I'm saying that the media controls
what's important in our minds if they
put on our screens that we look at for
eight hours a day that this is what we
need to care about then it's what we
care about and because they don't put
this on the screen people don't care
about it the only reason people see this
is because Elon bought Twitter and
that's allowed he said I agree with him
like that that's my point like people
don't care about this this isn't on the
media people were losing their minds
over covid because it was shoved down
their throats to the media but if you
didn't see it people should be if you
didn't see it for this though people
should be losing money they don't
because it's not in the media and they
don't go to hell I went through a I went
through the list of of every single
phase or drug that they make and I am
not on one of them by the grace of God
I'm healthy and I don't need need or
want to be on a single one of them
yeah
probably not but you do like things like
selected we see there's extra mutations
to try and see if we can make more
potent yeah so they're the areas
research I'm going about that I don't
know how that's gonna work it might not
be any more outbreaks because like Jesus
Christ the gentleman seems to have
absolutely no moral compass at all for
all government officials it's pretty
good for the industry to be honest yeah
it's bad for everyone else in America
it's good for the industry everybody
else doesn't know that once they
stopping at regularly work for the
company they're not going to be as hard
for them
if this is the quality of individuals
they're higher
regulations looking to hire The
Regulators so that The Regulators are on
their team and just you know it's clown
World clown worlds what is Pfizer doing
I guess to optimize you know the
vaccines now oh we actually have a
meeting of all that today so there's a
lot really
our undercover journalist asked Walker
how Pfizer is handling the fact that
their coveted vaccines are ineffective
against virus variants we're partnering
up with a Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom
Shea to hosts a 21-day virtual event
that you guys can join with us Tom is
going to teach you how to listen to your
mind in a new way and how to control it
so that you can have the discipline you
need to build the life you want so I've
seen this process done for 30 years when
you make it through you will be a
different human being the process is
simple but not easy because of the war
that's inside of us that few people have
been taught to fight overcoming your
excuses so if you're interested in
becoming a reformed human an absolute
animal go to tomshay.com and use Sunny
fast50 for 50 off of this program you
will not regret it you will be a changed
person at the end of it do not miss this
what he said is disturbing listen to
this we're exploring like now you know
virus keeps mutating yeah well one of
the things we're exploring is like why
don't we just mutate ourselves so we
could work I'm simply develop new
vaccines right so we have to do that if
we're going to do that though there's a
risk of like as you could imagine no one
wants to be having a farmer company
mutating
so that's like one of the things we're
considering okay like the future like
maybe we've been like create new
versions of the vaccines and things like
that okay see Pfizer ultimately is
thinking about mutating covet well that
is not what we say to the public no
that's right that came up in a meeting
and we were like why why do we not it
was like we're going to consider that
there'll be more discussions okay not
exactly actually right we're like wait a
minute
that's right it appears that Pfizer is
internally discussing the possibility of
mutating the covid virus themselves in
order to tailor a vaccine to sell to the
public listen to Walker describe in
detail project
who created this video and does a lot of
a lot of uh on mainstream media stories
they they rented a truck a digital truck
with digital screens all around it and
played this video on a loop on the truck
and parked it in front of Pfizer's
offices what'd they do about it New York
I don't know but I think it was pretty
cool move that is funny tail just how
they would conduct such a scientific
experiment first in living animals so
the way that we're thinking about it
don't tell anyone yeah so
um through it the way it would work is
like we put them in the virus in this
monkeys okay and then we successfully a
half a second a minute ago I just
thought okay maybe this is just like you
know this guy's just joking around like
Hey we're all talking like God yeah guys
we should just mutate the thing and then
make vaccines okay let's get back to the
agenda like it was a joke yeah yeah and
he's actually now talking about
nitty-gritty talking about how the how
how far down the road they thought about
this that they're talking about putting
it in monkeys and making for a little
monkeys suffer just so they can make
more money which is commonplace
unfortunately that's not even the sad
part about this whole thing and and that
is a sad part though awesome they're
keeping track to each other I would
collect serial samples from them and
then the ones are more infectious like
the virus we'll put them in another
monkey and just constantly actively
mutate it that's one way or you could
even do like directed like simulation
which like
and then you just sample what the
different like um like proteins on the
service device look like over time so
you can see the mutation you cannot
abortions
because you have to be like very
controlled to make sure that this virus
that you mutate so as you create
something like you know it's those
everywhere something crazy
read The Stand by Stephen King it's
about a virus that gets out of a
government lab no oh like always oh
Haywire it is one of the best books he
has ever written and he has written some
goddamn good books I'll have to check it
out you should at least watch it it is
actually a page Turner that you'll stay
up all night reading if not at least
watch the movie sounds good man to be
honest like it's no sense if this virus
popped out of nowhere like yeah I know
covet virus experimentation on live
monkeys this is unethical to say the
least and Walker describes those
experiments as if they are ongoing and
not simply a hypothetical discussion so
I mean when is Pfizer going to implement
the mutation of all these viruses
with all the experiments work out
because this is just like something
we're trying right it sounds like gain
of function to me
earlier he said it was something they
just talked about in a meeting and now
it's something they're trying so you
know the funny like this you know how
like where they are right now right like
what they're doing uh they're on a
they're on a date they're on a fake date
they're on a gay date
so he should have just gone all the way
have you seen the whole video because I
have and my favorite parts coming when
he flips out when he finds the truth
that he's been that's not in this video
but we can watch that okay I think it's
different it's like there's it's
definitely not getting a function it
sounds like it is I mean it's okay
so directed evolution is very different
direct Evolution directed Evolution
directed Evolution okay well so I mean
is that what it is
yeah so they're the areas research I'm
going about that I don't know how that's
gonna work we're not being more
outbreaks because like Jesus Christ so
um tell me more like what's developing
with the whole you know virus mutation
process
how does buddy not see this camera where
I need to see this setup crazy well
there's some kind of conducting the
experiments on it but I seems like
people have heard they're kind of
optimize anybody they're going slopes
everyone's very cautious like you know
right obviously accelerate it too much
yeah
um but I didn't also just try to do it
as an exploratory thing because you
obviously don't advertise that you're
tired throughout future invitations okay
so did that there's a whole virus
mutation thing like come from your
executive Sarah no no that came from
like we have like two scientific
officers in like the other divisions in
a subsequent meeting our undercover
journalist asked if this type of gain of
function research is already being
studied at Pfizer but no as long as it's
called directed evolution pfizers in the
clear what's the goal full advisor of
doing that so probably what they want to
do is like to try to figure out to some
extent try to figure out like you know
there's all these new strains of
variants that just pop up why don't we
try to like catch them before they pop
up in nature and we can develop a
vaccine propellectual for like new
variants yeah so that's why they're
thinking like if you do it controlling
the labs and say oh this is an epitope
and so then it comes out later on like
in the public we already have a vaccine
kind of working on it oh my God that's
perfect like isn't that like the best
business model though like just control
nature before nature even happens itself
right yeah yeah if it works what do you
mean if it works because like sometimes
it would just be taste this to pop up
right they were not prepared for it like
with Delta or Omicron right and things
like that so
who knows I mean either way it could be
a cash cow Kobe probably a cash cow for
us for a while going for it well yeah I
obviously like
well I think the whole you know this
dude's so evil oh my God
this is like straight that's the
straight villain laugh right there
clown world I think the whole like
research of the viruses and mutating it
like
would be the ultimate like Cash Cow yeah
now you would think that creating
viruses to sell the vaccine would be
illegal but no the pharmaceutical
industry as Walker puts it is quote a
revolving door for all government
officials unquote to all government
officials wow yeah for any industry
though so like in the Pharma industry
all the government officials who like
you know if you're our drugs especially
come work for pharmacies like the
military like all the like Army of
defense like government official events
are going to work for the defense
companies outwards how do you feel about
that revolving door like it's pretty
good for the industry to be honest yeah
yeah it's bad for everyone else in
America why is it bad for everybody else
because if the regular yourself to prove
our drugs know that once they're
shopping regularly they want to go work
for the company they got these hearts
out right we talked to Dr Robert Malone
physician scientist and author to get
his take on the comments made by Jordan
Walker you're gaining function you're
creating a new function in virus one by
adding elements from virus 2 infecting
one monkey and then another monkey
that's called cereal passage that
appears to have been one of the
Technologies deployed in the Wuhan
Institute of virology with the humanized
mouse strains that I believe were
obtained from uh it's crazy that he also
basically admitted that kovid was made
in a lab he said it doesn't make sense
it was just popped out of nowhere so
this whole scandemic that we had to go
through it was just made in a lab
something well that's what they were
saying from that's what Trump was saying
from the beginning and then they were
like racism how funny faces um to call
it the China virus it's racist like why
are we here defending China now why are
the Liberals not brainwashed he's not
like going after Chinese Americans
because Joe Biden makes millions and
millions of dollars on his son's
business dealings with China that's why
but um yeah that was crazy like people
he calls it the China virus like it
comes from China how is that racist it's
just true but you can call it calvid
it's like no man [__] China they should
be held accountable yeah they should
have been held accountable right from
the beginning but again they just does
it doesn't matter it's doesn't matter
what was said we had to make it racist
instead of making making it about facts
and it's coming out now where even the
people who said it was racist are like
oh yeah it may have been from the lab
maybe maybe might have happened it's
crazy man it's terrible Health Alliance
that's an example of directed Evolution
the gentleman seems to have absolutely
no moral compass at all about what he's
doing the hubris and arrogance and
immaturity if this is the quality of
individuals within Pfizer that are
making these huge decisions that risk
Global Public Health with such a casual
disregard or the human toll it's
profoundly corrupt in terms of would it
be feasible for Pfizer to circumvent
International or national law I think
that is undeniable and the gentleman in
your investigative work has clearly
indicated
that Pfizer believes that it has
successfully captured the regulatory
apparatus of the United States
government and presumably worldwide
Pfizer has completed regulatory capture
is quite proud of it with governments
turning a Blind Eye in Pfizer hiding
information from the public this is an
ongoing story be brave do something
spread these videos and stay tuned what
a disgrace because Pfizer always had a a
reputation as being a really solid
upstanding pharmaceutical company you
know that developed a lot of life-saving
medications that made people's lives
better or saved lives and now you've got
this piece of [__] out here going yeah
we're messing with the Cove advice we're
messing with it and trying to mutate it
so we can make more money because this
is a cash cow I'd like to know what I'd
like to know what happened to this guy
but I think we should talk onto this
video real quick his reaction when he
found out he was being recorded because
it's comedy gold hey there is your seat
taken you work for Pfizer my question
for you is why is Pfizer want to hide
from the public the fact that they're
mutating the covet viruses is this real
life I'm literally a liar I was trying
to impress a person on a date
because that suddenly that suddenly
gives you credibility now you lie on
dates to impress people you lie about
evil evil scientific clients you know
what this reminds me exactly of in
seventh grade I had a test where I
needed to know formulas so I wrote them
down on the table and hid them under my
notebook and then after the test I
forgot to erase them and so then I got
called back into the office because you
see writings where I sit you know who it
is so they call me back in and
immediately I'm like I just doodle
sometimes I zone out and I doodle so I
must have just doodled the doodled the
algorithm
lying I was lying like this dude is full
7th grade panic mode right now right
which but it's just hilarious that he's
trying to make himself sound like a
better person by saying he was a liar
look at buddy he got these sparkles on
his phone oh my God that's fine by the
way don't
I'm feeling unsafe every time that they
get confronted with a fact or even the
slightest thing that you know they want
to make into a fuss I'm feeling unsafe
and all of a sudden everybody goes okay
wait he's unsafe it's okay we can't make
anyone feel unsafe and everything stops
tough [__] life is unsafe sometime and
you create sometimes and you created
that situation for yourself by talking
out of school first of all this guy
can't be trusted either way if this is
going on in Pfizer and he's out talking
about it on a date you [__] you'll
have no business having any sort of
serious job if you if you have one drink
and you start spilling the family
secrets yeah that's crazy right oh yeah
and then if the other part's true which
we know is not that he's a liar to
impress somebody on a date you still
can't be trusted either way you're right
you're a snakey little rat okay no
characters
please unlock the door please unlock the
front and lock the door this is crazy
what a beat his ass he just throw it on
the ground
oh I would have that oh I'm sorry that
that whole thing got I would have cool
but whoa I would have hit him with the
one two Mayweather straight to these
straight to these pearly teeth of his
wow okay what a story what a story
that's not being covered by the
mainstream media pretty cool go get your
next shot don't forget your booster yeah
after you see this [__] thank you guys
so much for watching make sure to like
subscribe if you want a free preview on
how I've generated five million dollars
at age 19 no joke you can look up my
name and legit and articles of me on the
news will come out um if you want a free
preview join my Discord the Link's at
the top of the description and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]